dogs are our companions but they're also
living proof of artificial selection
dogs have a unique relationship with
humans they have co-evolved and have
adapted to live in our human-like world
around us
they descended from a gray wolf like
ancestors and they are one of the first
animals if not the first animal to have
been domesticated in the last 30 or so
years we've seen a huge boom when it
comes to studying dog cognition and dog
behavior this is dr biozier a dog
cognition researcher let's have her walk
through some key canine communication
behaviors you can observe at home that
demonstrate our unique co-evolution with
dogs
[Music]
wendy
oh can i give you both snacks this
movement that you see in your dog's eyes
when they look at you when they gaze up
staring at you lovingly wanting snacks
we call it puppy dog eyes but in fact
this is the eye musculature that we see
more defined in the dogs we have in our
homes and particularly we see this
through the levator muscles that they
have located just around their eyes it
gives them more control in a sense over
how they move their eyes so we can be
very expressive in how we move our
eyebrows just using them in conversation
lifting them up and these muscles that
are more present in our dogs that we
have at home it allows them to kind of
wiggle those little
spotty dotty hairy bits that they have
right above their eyebrows potentially
making them more expressly communicative
or potentially just making them a little
bit more manipulative to get more snacks
a 2019 study compared these upper eyelid
muscles and found that they were much
more prominent in dogs than in wolves
except the siberian husky which is more
closely related to wolves
when you look at huskies and malamutes
that musculature is less defined and
actually more similar to what you see in
wolves where those muscles are hardly
present so basically we bred big cute
puppy eyes into modern canines as humans
our attention is drawn towards the eyes
and so we like dogs that have large eyes
another clear example of our
co-evolution with dogs is that they seem
to understand what we mean when we point
to something
research currently suggests that dogs
outperform every other living species on
the human given pointing task two choice
object discrimination task is typically
what's done to evaluate pointing
comprehension in dogs and you can
actually try this at home with your own
dog the idea is that you have two
containers both of which have treats
taped on the inside so they smell
equally like food however one of them
will have an additional treat on the
inside for the dog to obtain human
experimenter will sit directly in front
of a dog and give a gesture then you let
the dog make a choice the one with the
snack that you've pointed to or they can
pick the other one andy
good job
so is this something that dogs have
learned from us or has pointing been
selected into them by living alongside
us for thousands of years wolves
potentially would not have a need per se
to follow the human given pointing skill
their environment may not consist of a
human they may actually be more fearful
towards humans and so the world in which
dogs live really is a human focused one
if we as humans use it to communicate
with one another dogs that live
alongside us could also benefit from
understanding certain behaviors
good job
eye contact is extremely important in
humans it's where we automatically first
look when we look at other individuals
and the eyes are extremely communicative
this is something that is kind of unique
in the sense that many animals don't
expressly like making eye contact
however if you were to try to sit at
home and look at your dog and stare
lovingly into their eyes odds are is
that they'll look back at you so we have
a very cool feature which is that our
whites around our eyes known as the
sclera they are white and this means
that when you look from side to side
that you can start to identify
things like where an individual is
looking this can be really important for
communication and it's actually
something that dogs have seemingly
picked up on one way to show this
clearly is the impossible task
experiment
you have a tupperware container filled
with a toy and you don't lock the lid on
the tupperware container in place let
your dog explore have them sniff it out
check it out and obtain whatever reward
you've placed in there you keep doing
this a couple of times just to make sure
that they can get the snack and that the
reward is solvable however when it comes
to the test trial in the unsolvable
paradigm the idea is that you lock the
tupperware lid in place so that the
reward is no longer accessible and you
let the dog go and you try to see what
do they do and what happens with a lot
of dogs is that they actually sit down
and will wait for someone to help them
out and will make eye contact with
someone who's available to make eye
contact researchers have long documented
that dogs understand when a human is
focusing their attention on them you can
try this at home you can grab a snack
place it in front of you with your dog
directly across ask them to wait leave
it stare at them see what they'll do
give them about 10 seconds i would say
and see if they approach you and if they
don't let them come and eat the snack
okay
then i would do this again put the snack
on the ground but turn around and give
them another 10 seconds and see if they
actually eat the snack
sneak
so dogs pay attention to human attention
they're aware when we stare at them they
might even enjoy it thanks to the love
hormones we both share when wendy here
takes a look into my eyes what ends up
happening is that we both have increases
in lung hormones like oxytocin and
dopamine and prolactin which you
actually see in the maternal bonds
humans have an increase as well when we
stare into our dog's eyes dogs also have
an increase in these love hormones as
well and how do we know this you look at
saliva samples so you have humans and
dogs chew on various objects before and
after interacting with one another and
you evaluate differences in the types of
hormones that are present in their
systems when we interact in certain ways
like petting or hanging out you see
increased dopamine and oxytocin love
hormones which means that it makes us
feel good as humans and it also makes
dogs feel good humans and dogs speak to
each other with their voices and their
barks respectively but a 2007 dog
cognition experiment in hungary revealed
there are six types of barks that humans
can identify when a dog is scared or
fearful
another one was an excited bark while an
individual was playing with the dog
something's going on in the neighborhood
where dogs are left alone
but there could be more barks it could
be that certain dog barks are intended
for human understanding
cats meow not to talk to other cats but
essentially to talk to humans wolves are
more likely to howl in a certain way and
are less likely to bark and so it could
be that that barking that you hear at
home is actually something that is
really intended for you as the owner
working dogs like police dogs and seeing
eye dogs have all been trained and seem
to excel in language but even your
average layabout could have a vocabulary
of dozens potentially hundreds of words
sit
good boy
most dogs are familiar with the words
that are relevant to them and the words
that are important to them sadie where's
your duck
okay
good job
so there's a great study that looked at
something called the cocktail phenomenon
wendy hi
hi
so when you call over wendy in a crowded
room the idea is that wendy also pays
attention just like if someone were to
call my name in a crowded room my
interest is piqued and i peek up just
like wendy does when she hears her name
in a crowded area so what about these
tick-tock dogs like stella or bunny who
seem to string together human speech by
pressing a specially designed voice pad
there's this big trend right now where
we have dogs that have learned to push
buttons that have a voice recording of
the owner associated with them
wow but like you know did she actually
poop outside or something you know like
you were saying it would just be nice to
have a bit more context to these just so
we know like what comes before what
comes after yeah when they string words
together i don't think we have enough
evidence right now to say that they are
understanding the grammar and the syntax
that's associated with what those words
mean however this could be something
that over time we learn is actually what
they're doing so are we as humans with
our breeding practices artificially
selecting for dogs with certain traits
or is this something that they're able
to learn easily in very early stages of
life and throughout their individual
lifetimes
there could have been genetic
predispositions for many of these things
that we then also indirectly selected
for or maybe even directly selected for
and that have inadvertently resulted in
dogs who are really
successful at learning quickly so it
could in fact be that it is not nature
versus nurture that it is a combination
of all of the above dogs are really
going that extra mile when it comes to
communicating with humans when it comes
to understanding our body language
fitting into our
mold of what we want them to be living
in the cities dogs really have to put up
with a lot when it comes to living with
humans and one of the things that's
quite remarkable is the fact that dogs
can understand and identify thousands of
words and we as humans can only
potentially identify six barks and so
this discrepancy shows that we as humans
actually have a lot of learning that we
could do if we want to stand up to what
our dogs are actually capable of
understanding when it comes to us
[Music]
you